it says use the perpendicular distance
formula to determine how many times each
line intersects the given circle so
here's the first one that's the rubble
of this out fairly quickly but 5 plus 0
I'll leaves to space ok so before we
tackle this question and before you just
handle it algebraically cause you can
let's just try and picture what's
happening on this line up the top
general form is wonderful because
everything can be put in general form
but it's not very helpful to see what it
looks like so help me out a little bit
let's put this in point gradient for do
you think we can do it in one here yes
we can right I just want y to be the
subject ok I'm going to move this guy
over here so I'm going to leave the
sides off for a second because i'm going
to change the science in two minutes I'm
just going to put the 3x over there one
with the 16 over there as well and i
need to divide by negative 5 right so
this is going to become so the negative
it came over will cancel and it'll be
divided by 5 right and then the negative
that comes over with this will also get
cancelled why do the other wise you know
why everything's pretty it's it's all
this it's all the same that's all the
same oh this is a picture of Oregon okay
ah where does this graph go let's see
you've got a y-intercept of 16 / 5 which
is just a bit above just a bit about
three right so if I went like one two
three that's terrible anyway just above
ok and its gradient is increasing its
three-fifths so it's not it's not super
statement it's doing something like this
okay now when you get a picture of this
circle x squared plus y squared equals
five what's the radius of the circle
the radio the circle is a square root of
5 because this guy over here is R
squared it's a bit naughty isn't it okay
what is the squared five ish it's like
to point yeah I checkpoint whatever okay
so if you're looking at something like
let's see this we said this was just on
three yeah right so I'm guessing
something like that roughly speaking
okay now the thing is because it's
roughly speaking I don't know if it's
like a bit smaller or it's just all of
the teja so how do we work this out in
more detail okay well if you think about
like how do you work out whether
something intersect or not right for
instance right what are the special
cases is you've got the center of the
circle right there okay so if I as a
line over here and the exactly route
five away from the center of the circle
right no matter where I am like what
direction up going in if I'm route 5 for
instance this line over here is exactly
route 5 away from the center right can
you see why I can see that because route
5 is the radius and the radius will be
perpendicular and this is a
perpendicular distance formula right
again if I was root 5 but I was offered
a diff angle like over here right that's
still gonna leave at five could still
the radius and i'm still a tangent so
now you can see if I greater than root 5
units away from the set up right the
center which is this if I'm rather the
root 5 away from there I'll never touch
third chance it doesn't matter where I'm
going to be i'll be like out here or out
here or something like that okay I'll
never get within range enough to
actually be tangent to the circle so if
I'm further if the distance is greater
than root 5 right sorry that means no
intersection right
yeah yeah you should have I mean this is
this is all quite a giant rate in a
sense right if as I was receiving
distance is exactly root 5 at how many
times only sex once because I'm tangent
and if I'm less than root 5 then I'm
going to slice right through the circle
and I'm going to here twice okay so
there's this make sense so you can see
how reasoning it right and how I've take
advantage of this formula which is
perpendicular to use a property the
circle table it's it's radius is going
to be that distance line yep see that's
right so for instance if you find this
and you suppose you know this distance
here is too that's less than root fired
so I'm we did range i'm going to hit
twice um darn you need to chest this
point which is the center that's where
i'm measuring from right all the way up
until this line and that'll only give
you a single value sees the point yeah
why that's exactly right